Cat Williams called out Kim K what do
you expect the guy married a like
what and roasted Steve Harvey not one of
them asked for a country bumpkin black
dude that can't talk good over and look
like Mr Potato Head there ain't none
these are the top three most intense
moments from Cat Williams on Club Shay
starting off with his comments about
making another Friday movie with Chris
Tucker and um the Chris Tucker that we
got now is Epstein Island Chris Tucker
Oh not
oh Lord Mercy up next is cats claims
that Kevin Hart is an industry plant no
we've never heard of that before that
person or sense that person what do you
think a plant is maybe people don't
understand the definitions of these
words and at number one on this list is
when